come on in you'll see an orange chair
that's your chair
orangey I recommend coming around I like
to challenge myself that but I'll go
I'll do what you tell me to do there you
go
Jennifer so great to see you here on
frontrunner so happy to be here really
appreciate you being here
the rolling cake Claire is such a great
character did you chase this movie or
did they chase you oh I read it and it
was with in someone else's hands oh I
really was like ah I think I know what
to do with this I really think I do and
are you a if it's meant to be it will
happen kind of person yeah always
anything that you i 100% believe that i
don't ever feel like regretful of oh I
should have taken that look what
happened to that or you know I think
everybody is meant to do whatever it is
that they're meant to do also we asked
everybody on this show if there's a
moment earlier in their career that
stands out as a pivotal moment for you a
moment where you thought you could do
something exciting with acting yes
besides waitressing I I actually do
remember I was when I was 18 years old
and I was doing my first off-broadway
play at the Public Theater which for me
at the time was kind of a huge deal
what was it call it was called for dear
life okay with Tony Shalhoub oh I had
one scene in particular where we were
having like a sleepover a slumber party
and I say I sit up and I face the
audience and I say a line that would or
sometimes it usually should get a laugh
and this one time I I stood up God took
my position look straight out and into
the audience and there was a Latino and
Diane Keaton and they were laughing
really hard and I froze a my heart
stopped I don't think I remembered my
next line but I I do remember thinking I
just made that Wow
but that's scary for a young actress if
you do have to have a moment where you
do need to face the crowd because no
matter who was in it I would imagine to
see people's faces with the distract oh
you are a few you're met with like it's
like the worst you've snarl I would
usually not I would it would try to get
kind of go to a blank space but this
time I just don't know why I lucked upon
those faces well I'm glad it worked out
for you yeah a movie that is getting
everyone to talk about you right now is
cake so I want to take a look
at one of my favorite scenes from cake
its thing that you like to we're gonna
watch it together with those remotes in
our hands posit and dissect key moments
so this is a scene with you and Adriana
Barraza who plays her housekeeper and
you're not too happy with her because
she has invited over this guy that
you've just gotten to know for lunch
with his young son you're not too
thrilled yeah let's do a look okay
Silvana so cute yes I love how guilty
you she is she's about to get no tongue
lashing so you have this habit of
letting everyone into the house okay I
have to start by talking about the look
of Claire because the hair is matted
down she has scars on her face for
reasons that I don't want to get into so
as not to spoil things but the look is
definitely non-glamorous was that
exciting for you was it scary for you
was it liberating for you to play you
know what it wasn't scary
it was quite liberating it was also that
was the byproduct of who this woman is
what she's been living through the last
year and change not quite taking care of
herself and that's what you get so that
for me I was just thrilled I mean to be
honestly portraying someone that was in
that position and when people ask me to
describe what's that movie cake that
Jennifer Anderson said I'd say it's a
woman who's in every kind of pain
imagined imaginable physical mental
emotional yep yeah yeah well let's see
how this goes okay but he's a friend huh
and I think you get angry my boy what I
invite him and his boy for lunch today
after tomorrow
what now I love the relationship between
Claire and Silvana cuz it has so many
different facets you know she's the
housekeeper but she's also a mom she's
my mother my caretaker my guardian angel
she's she's everything and she takes the
abuse the the sort of stubbornness and
toughness that she has to deal with with
my character and there's it's a
beautiful love story they really I mean
it's not only her loss but it's
Adriana's loss Sylvanas loss as well
yeah they have some sweet moments John a
sweet which are nice to see ya okay
let's keep going I make that - you don't
make that - no I don't care I don't give
it well that's not the point
I like that moment because it does walk
that line between comedy and drama
I feel comedy and drama and go hand in
hand we don't walk through life just
only being very serious there's always
some there's always a lighter light
moments and that's always honestly one
of the things that I loved about that
aspect when reading this script you you
there were moments where you actually
laughed at this woman and you saw like a
former shadow of who she was this funny
acerbic ballbusting lawyer you know like
and you so there's little little shards
of light of who she used to be waiting
to come out find a way to come in and
there is that levity yeah you know I can
hear some work well what did he say I
want to talk about those last few
seconds there because just to watch you
walking it's so obvious that Claire is a
woman in pain how did you go about
coming up with the way that she would
carry herself and move first it started
with physics the physicality of where
the accident took place what it was
broken so my right leg my back my next
face was shattered shard you know and
then what would that be like stiffness
and the in the ribcage not being able to
move properly and just constantly
getting up in pain just moving as though
you are living with excruciating pain
mm-hm and it really kind of becomes
second nature honestly well after once
so you jointed you actually had
crewmembers remember if you just would
start to help me up and oh wow but we're
being very cautious of me because it
kind of one of those things where if you
stopped sort of living in the in the
physicality of it
you know you lose it it's like taking
your pumps off at a wedding and then
wishing you didn't because putting it
back on again is just toxic
did it ever become almost psychosomatic
where you found yourself like this
actually really don't know you do you
totally I would Albin on weekends it was
all about body work and getting the
kinks out cuz you know definitely in the
neck and in the back especially yeah
here's the rest of the scene you say yes
good
good
what I like there is a moment there is
really all about the silence and so much
of what you're known for from friends to
some of the films that you've done is
this kind of hyper verbal very fast
you're always very articulate usually in
your characters this is a woman who
lives in the silences a lot particularly
in that moment was that interesting to
play well in that moment yeah because
there's so much she's digesting the
frustration with that this is now going
to happen the sort of quiet excitement
that it is going to happen the sort of
just taking in all of those little bits
of reality that are sort of flooding
like a speeding bullet through her brain
yeah and that invitation that Silvana
makes opens the door to a really
interesting new relationship in Claire's
life doesn't yeah for sure so thank you
so vana
thank you Silvana for a lot of things
but I guess that one especially well
it's a great great scene so I appreciate
you taking some time to talk about it
thank you so much love it now if you
have not seen kake be sure to check it
out in theaters and thanks so much for
watching
Fandango frontrunner to say thank you
yes for joining us today we have made
you your own Fandango gift card so nice
and now the only last thing you have to
do is take an iPad photo with me like a
little selfie yeah okay okay and this is
just a little social media thing me and
social media are like yeah right three
two one good job great to see you
congratulations thank you so much I'm so
excited for you
you